All right,
let's get started.
Here we go again.
That's had some fun again today.
A notice of course we have the sign in sheet when you come in every morning.
Great thing to do as we say.
Ah,
this is not the world's most demanding class,
but one thing we do ask you to do,
he has come to the lectures and come to section.
Um,
you may know if someday you are,
in fact,
you'll get an email message from me about a half hour after class is over.
So sorry to hear that you were sick this morning.
Uh,
hope you're feeling better very soon.
so we do,
we do look after these things.
Such an email went out last time,
but I'm preaching to the converted because you're,
you guys are already here.
So good for you.
Let's continue with the discussion of
the elements of music who are going to be working today with harmony.
So far we've had two sessions specifically on rhythm to special session,
specifically on melody.
And today we come to harmony.
Harmony is one of the two things that really distinguishes the music of Western
civilization.
Western classical music,
western pop music.
What are the two things?
Well,
as mentioned before,
this dependence upon a heavy usage of Witten musical notation,
not so much into pop music,
but certainly in the classical music,
writing it all down,
being able to manipulate it in that fashion.
So that's one thing that distinguishes western classical music.
And the other aspect of we're talking about today is harmony.
Stop and think about it.
Think about the melodies of China and Japan.
Virtually every and and Islamic countries,
virtually every musical civilization around the world has more sophisticated
melodies than we do in the west.
Hours are very blunt in a way.
They go from one discrete frequency to another discrete frequency to another
discrete frequency.
And they're not making use of all of the material in between in any sort of
nuanced way.
Maybe it's because we're so dependent on the keyboard here.
Uh,
so that's,
that's important to keep in mind.
But let's talk about rhythm for a moment.
Is Western,
uh,
rhythm particularly sophisticated?
I was listening as I was coming in this morning.
That'd be [inaudible] and are they had a Strauss waltz playing there?
Oompah whom par par,
how sophisticated is that?
Rhythmically think of African music where you have one downbeat and one pattern
working against another downbeat and another pattern.
Caribbean music,
African influence,
the same kind of thing.
It's world a head in terms of sophistication with regard to rhythm,
but the one thing that distinguished a western music is this idea of harmony,
this concept of super imposing,
multiple pitches,
interesting idea.
You know that,
that you have this,
this sound and you've been another one but another one with another one.
Something like that and you can play with these and and manipulate these in
interesting kinds of ways.
So piling up sounds simultaneously.
This idea of harmony,
it's what makes Western music very special and what we end up with here,
I just reached for anything in my office here is the overture to a score of a
Mozart opera and look here how many parts we have playing simultaneously.
Some of them may be repeating pitch names,
somebody may be playing see here and somebody else's see up there,
that sort of thing.
There may be duplicating pitch names,
but you could have anywhere up to 10 wellness case about 15 different sounds
going at once and you don't get that in other musical cultures.
Let's talk for a moment about chords.
What's a cord?
Will a court,
it's just a simultaneous sounding of two or more pitches.
That's a very basic general definition of a cord.
And a cord can be of course consonant
or it can be
dissonant,
dissonant.
So let's stick with just consonant chords should be working with consonant
chords today.
And the most fundamental of the consonant chords is this idea of the triad.
This figure that we call the triad,
it's the building block really of all our harmonies,
whether it's a pop or classical.
And we're going to use a lot of pop music today and there'll be,
we'll be pointing up a triax there in this pop music.
So what's a triad?
Well,
obviously you get the idea of three pitches,
three pitches,
how's it work?
Let's go over to the keyboard and the staff here.
Let's say
we've got a scale and we do have a scale CD.
He have ga BCE.
And I wanted to construct a triad above each of these notes of the scale.
Well,
I take the,
this happens to be a c middle c hears.
So I try it is going to have three pitches you and it spans five letter names
and we go one,
one letter name,
two letter names,
three later named four letter names,
five letter names.
We take one three and five year.
I'm taking cs,
skipping d,
taking III,
skipping F and taking g and it gives me this three note aggregate.
Take one,
skip,
take one,
skip take one.
Yeah,
Todd,
I'm Bot.
Um,
and we can do the same thing.
Todd,
ah,
and so on,
right up the,
the scale in that fashion.
No,
this,
as we said before,
we've got this scale and we've got some nodes.
Rather important in the scale of tonic is very important.
We said the Yod home,
the leading tone is important.
So with cords and triads,
some are very important.
The tonic is very important and this dominant,
what we call the dominant,
it's not really the most important.
It.
It sort of leads into pools into it,
particularly important.
Setting up the tiny,
it's the next important.
Right below that is this sub dominant.
It often pulls into the dominant,
which then pulls into the titanic in that fashion.
So we would get this idea of here's a chord here,
here's the tonic,
here's the dominated,
there's a subdominant and there's the tunnel.
We can flip this just a little bit.
We could say,
all right,
here's our Tomanek up here.
Long bomb bomb bomb
go that way.
Tonic subdominant dominant tonic
that way.
So we could go come up from the time or go down from the tiny,
generally speaking,
the composers are more likely to go down from the tonic and then come back up to
the tonic.
Then they aren't likely to go to the other way.
So we've got these three basic chords we're going to talk about.
There are others there that we built on the second and seventh degree of the
scale,
but these are the most important and it's surprising how much music these three
basic chords can accommodate all the things
dominant.
Subdominant Tanya.
So a lot of lot of,
uh,
music is made in that fashion.
One of my favorite pieces,
and I thought it was because it,
it's a good teaching piece.
Uh,
and I thought it was known just to me and other old codgers is a good cowboy
song called streets of Laredo.
But last night I looked it up on youtube,
not on youtube or iTunes and you know,
there are 139 s the recordings at that that you can buy now.
Johnny Cash Arlo Guthrie.
Um,
but I'd be interested,
anybody ever heard that before?
Raise your hand if you've heard that.
One,
two,
three.
Well,
a few people.
So it's a,
it's a,
it's a cowboy song.
Walked the streets,
I
was dressed in white linens,
dressed in white,
says call.
And as I was singing,
all I was doing underneath was playing the basic harmony,
the courts.
And it consists just of two courts
dominant
fashion.
Oh,
why the courts had,
why,
why do we do that?
Why don't we have to change these cords?
Any ideas?
Why don't we,
why don't this,
why don't you just say
no street?
Why do we change court?
Yeah,
the melody changes.
And because the melody changes to keep banging that same Agri and against it,
it's going to create what a distance and we don't want,
we don't like distance.
There's,
if we're going to have this,
we got to control them.
Uh,
you know,
if,
unless I change that cord underneath when I get up,
sorry,
this is,
it doesn't sound very silent for silent night there.
So I need to,
to switch to another
and then switching back to the original one.
So we change chords to make the harmony constant or to make the harmony
harmonious,
harmonious.
All right,
so that,
that's uh,
uh,
something that we need to keep in mind.
Here's something else that's were we're going to ask you to focus on and that is
the rate of harmonic change.
The rate of harmonic change will really be asking you to things.
Is the harmony changing?
Okay?
Can you,
is the harmony changing or is it static?
And if it is changing,
is it changing at eight regular or you regular rate by regular rate?
Every time of chord sounds it will be holding for exactly the same amount of
time.
Let's go back to streets of Laredo.
One,
two,
three
mano.
Hey.
Aw,
aw,
oh,
aw.
What do you think?
Regular or irregular?
Regular.
Okay.
Um,
but no.
Uh,
well,
okay,
so that's regular.
Let's go onto another one.
Okay.
Doing a lot there in the base to make it more interesting,
but let's strip that down just to the fundamental core that's underneath that.
So we're targeting,
we're sitting here on the tonic chord and we'll go
la,
la La Blah Blah,
blah.
La La,
la,
la.
We could even count it out.
One to two to three
to move forward.
Oh,
one,
two,
three.
Heat to before.
So some chords they're holding for I guess four,
four measures for bars and some for two and some for just one.
So that's an irregular rate of harmony change.
So we're not going to be asking you a is are we did well,
what court do we have here and expect you to say subdominant or what chord we
have you here expect you to say dominant.
We're going to be working with more fundamental things.
Is the harmony changing?
Is it changing it a regular or irregular irregular rate.
Uh,
okay.
Notice I was playing up here.
Oh,
jingle bells.
So what is it in music that sets
the harmony?
What part?
Who,
what's the foundation of harmony?
What instrument plays it?
Where in the texture is the,
are we talking high,
low,
middle,
low?
It's the base.
The base is,
it's like these pillars.
I think of architecture.
You get,
you know,
your,
you put these pilings in and then you can build other things around it.
Well those basic notes,
the tonic note,
the dominant knows the subdominant.
There's sort of the pilings,
then you can ornament around the pilot.
That's just a,
I could go in that fashion that would be simple from dominant to tonic or I
could make it a little more interesting.
And that's kind of what bass players do.
Uh,
whether they're playing electric bass in a rock band,
um,
maybe in even more sophisticated weight and acoustic bass in a symphony or a
double bass in a bluegrass band.
And who is the world's most famous double Bass player in a boot blue grass bed?
Anybody know?
Well,
thank here at,
yeah.
Well we'll see what we've got here.
Let Brian,
if you could bring up this particular video.
This is one is this world famous bass player.
I was kind enough to loan me.
It was something put together by a Kentucky public television.
So let's bring up this screen.
Okay,
good.
Let's pause it here just for a second.
So here's the setup and we're going to turn off the lights.
We've got,
um,
a DVD from Kentucky public television involving,
as you will see,
some people that may look familiar is this person look familiar.
Anybody know this person?
She's a student run here.
She was a Yale undergraduate,
and she's telling us how she tried out for the Yale Symphony Orchestra and she
was designated as an alternate and she was Crestfallen,
but she then saw this ad where people wanted her to play in a bluegrass band.
So let's watch what happens
trapped in a classical violinist body.
So I guess they were kind of pessimistic about finding a real fiddle player.
So,
um,
so she is like,
you're from West Virginia,
you should go down there and audition for that.
And a,
so luckily no other fiddle player showed up.
Um,
bear like film.
And I was like,
Mozart.
Um,
so,
uh,
so they were very kind and let me,
you know,
kind of get my training on the job.
And so I started playing with them at that point and it's just been great ever
since.
Darlin please.
Beneath the ground.
Okay,
let's pause it here just for a second.
So a mystery basic layer is
Peter Salovey's,
the new provost.
And I said I'd send him an email.
Say,
Peter,
look,
we're teaching base over here.
Once you come in,
bring your,
bring your base here and you can demonstrate this stuff a little bit busy
at the moment.
But I got this DVD,
you can have this DVD and do what ever you want it to with.
So,
uh,
what's he doing there?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And he's working around these particular notes.
In this particular piece we're going to say,
here's a seat.
Um,
do you bar,
there's this sub done follow bump,
bump bump there go bom,
Bom,
bom,
Bom and oftentime.
He's going bom,
Bom,
Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom Bom,
bom.
But again,
it's just fleshing out that subdominant chord,
dominant chord and tonic chord.
And it's,
and we can all hear this.
I mean,
do we see,
does this guy playing off of music again and get,
of course the point not using music.
How were they doing this?
They're hearing the courts,
they're hearing tonic subdominant and dominant and I think we can hear them to
anybody out there hearing these cords.
Can you sing along with these,
this wonderful music?
It's great.
All right.
How many like this music,
it's happy music again.
Uh,
we should have a whole course on bluegrass music.
A good,
would we be really be good because a lot of interesting ethnic issues involved
in it.
Uh,
so let's continue here and all sort of bang on the piano or seeing the basic
pictures of the base.
And I hope you'll join with me here.
Um,
if you don't like blue grass,
you don't have to sing,
but if you like the book where I sing along with me here.
Okay,
here we go.
Whoops.
TV movies
here.
Craig.
Yeah,
maybe that's it.
I could listen to this all day.
I Dunno.
It was just too goofy or stay with history or ditch this.
Uh,
I think it's a wonderful,
but you seem less excited about [inaudible].
All right,
so let's,
let's turn the lights back and we'll get back to Mozart and stuff like stuff
like that.
Um,
let's talk about how these bases,
we said that the bass note is sort of the foundation and then you add these
other things up above it and they produce these chords and the courts are tonic
and dominants and so on.
Sometimes if you're have a solo instrument,
the you can play the basis just a cord
or you could play it the same notes but spinning them out.
And we call that an Arpeggio probably cause with the harps play this a lot to
sort of harp edge,
taking the notes of a triad and just spinning them out in six sessions.
Um,
and Arpeggios work particularly well with one triage with pieces that happened
to be in three,
one,
two,
three,
one,
two,
three.
So that's our pitch.
Just a cord.
The notes played successively to create an Arpeggio.
It works less.
These triadic Arpeggios with pieces and two,
that's not so good,
right?
Metrical train wreck there.
Uh,
so,
uh,
what we would do with that will be fine.
Another pattern.
One of the favorite patterns ever since the 18th century was this thing called
an owl Berti base.
It goes one then up to the fifth degree of the triad,
one five,
three,
five,
one five,
three,
five.
It sounds very classical,
but that's a good way of harmonizing a um,
uh,
something,
making something that's not very interesting.
Sound more interesting.
Another way of doing it is just taking a note,
Boogie Woogie base.
You could just take optives rolls that way.
Beethoven does this and this auto
so on.
So there you can get though the harmony to sound more interesting simply by
rolling that Optiv underneath.
So all of these little tricks,
uh,
sort of energize the music and again,
make it more interesting is that it otherwise perhaps would be sometimes if
sometimes harmonies can stand by themselves.
Sometimes you could take just the harmony and it would be very beautiful.
Js Bach,
I should get my music up here,
which my music js Bach wrote a prelude to the first book of his well-tempered
clubbier and it's a famous work.
It goes this way.
And so all it really is
six
sessions of chords played as our pitch CIOs.
So there it's sad for about,
well I could say rather specifically about 140 years or so.
And the French composer in the 19th century trough no,
came along and said,
well gee,
that's nice,
but I could write a melody against that.
So we're going to listen to this,
listen to box harmony underneath.
Uh,
at the same time we listened to this lovely melody that Charles [inaudible]
composed for it,
uh,
and it gives us a chance to think about melody and it gives us a chance to think
about the sound of the cello.
The cello is a particularly beautiful instrument.
I've always said if I ever come back as a musical instrument,
I want to come back as a cello.
It's just so rich and so beautiful and consortia.
So let's listen to a lovely cello line added over top of box,
original harmony
descending sequence here.
That pattern shows up again,
but a lower step,
it sounds as if he's going to do it yet.
A third time
it takes that we know
the rest of this arching
get to this building higher
Meyer.
Okay,
so we'll stop it.
There.
It comes back to the tonic after that lovely climates at the top of that.
So we need to point out that we've got these two types of courts here.
The idea of the,
this was all in c major,
but we could turn this into c minor.
Let's go back and review this.
We have up on the board again the scale
and we need to talk about these triads that are made up of either major or minor
thirds here.
We could look at it this way with this particular interval in this particular
involve.
Let's go over to the keyboard here cause I think it's easier to show here.
So I'm going to start here with C,
uh,
because you know,
sees kind of revenue neutral.
We'll start here with C and we're going to take the skip one,
take one,
skip one,
take one.
So we get C,
e g notice coming up here,
we have one,
two,
three,
four half steps here.
This is an interval.
This interval from c up to e is the interval of a third because it spans three
letter names.
C Up to g is a fifth.
It spans five letter names.
So we have c d e being a third with one,
two,
three,
four steps in it,
half steps.
Now we're going to go from e up to G.
Notice here we get one,
two,
three,
just three.
And that's because I said before we've got this arbitrary division of the octave
according to Greek and mathematics,
on to which in the ninth and 10th and 11th century,
the Benedictine monks laid on another system that didn't quite work.
So up here,
this all seems to be the same.
Distance e to f seems to be the same distance as d,
but it's not.
It's only half the distance.
So we get this funny junction in the keyboard here,
but in any event,
the important thing to note is that we have a major triad with the big third on
the bottom and the little third on the top.
If we switched this around them and went to see e flat g to give us the minor
triad,
then of course we would have just three half steps here and four here.
Um,
were,
were reciprocal angles or something like,
yet you change one ipso facto,
you change the other.
But that's all that's in play.
And we've seen this in play before.
Just the positioning of that third will determine whether this triad is a major
triad or a minor.
It,
let's see how this works out in terms of real sound.
Um,
I'd like to do you guys down here y'all,
I'm just hold that pitch.
Aw.
And Tas,
can you sing the fifth law and Nice and loud everybody and everyone else.
Your,
there's the major third work with me.
Everybody else saying that.
Third.
Ah,
we're going to go minor.
Uh Huh.
Major,
minor,
Major.
And it's just,
just tweaking,
just tweaking that middle note of the trial there.
That's all that should really involve in composers have tweaked this.
Here's a piece by France list.
It re orchestrated by contemporary composer called lugubrious Gondola in French
or in English translating from the French.
Let's listen to a bit of,
it starts out with a woodwind instrument.
What would win instrument is playing here.
And then we'll focus on the change from one triad to the next.
Hey,
let's stop there.
There's a positive right there.
So what instrument was that?
Did you pick that up?
Yeah,
I was a clarinet.
If we're doing this on a,
on a quiz or test,
we probably played that three times.
Did you hear it?
A lot more than just that.
But it was a clarinet.
Now we go to this sound
and watch what happens,
moves to another core
major,
minor,
Major.
Bye.
Yeah,
let's pause it there and reset this just a little bit.
Because underneath,
underneath,
what's the base doing here?
What's that?
Arpeggio?
Yeah,
just an Arpeggio.
So sometimes they take these cores and we just use it as an arpeggiated support.
That's all Puccini does by waiver harmonic support.
They're just takes that tonic chord
basically just works.
That is an Arpeggio or page you underneath.
Um,
all right.
So let's see how if we can begin to hear the distinction between a major triad
in a minor try.
And for this,
we're going to turn to a very famous piece,
the Moonlight Sonata of Beethoven.
Uh,
and I ask you if you got this paper there.
I hope you do.
Um,
uh,
we're,
we're going to play 19 cords for you and we're going to ask you which is major
in which is minor.
So you know the piece.
So I'm going to sort of strip these down to their essence here.
Here's court number one,
major or minor.
Try it.
Here's cord number two.
Here's three,
four
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
91011121314
and late teens.
So how'd you do it?
Well,
let's,
let's see here.
Let's go back and double check.
Well that's a minor chord.
I'll just tell you the answers here.
It's major.
This is minor.
Three is minor
for his minor about that one.
That may be tough one.
Is that a major corridor
major?
Some of these are hard though.
Major,
minor,
Major.
Okay.
That was six here.
She was making 17 major eight years.
Nine Years Major.
10 is major.
11 is minor.
12 with major.
13 is minor.
41516171819.
So it would be working.
This I think is fair game.
Just to differentiate between a major,
try it as a minor to try it and we'll be doing that all the test that week from,
from Dale.
But we'll be giving you lots of prepping in that in section a section this week.
Uh,
let's return to the pop realm and its focus a continually here on harmony and
combine the idea of harmony with major and minor tribe.
And I play a piece that I've always liked a by you too.
I don't really know much about them but it's an interesting piece.
Love is blind in this.
Let's listen to chunks of this.
Um,
and uh,
we'll see what they're doing with the harmony here.
Wow.
What's the meter?
Kind of a slow one.
Okay.
So for copyright reasons we're cutting is exactly sure.
We don't want to go over a limit here.
Okay.
So we're going to skip ahead and I will listen to just a little bit more yard
that I think that's kind of the beat,
you know,
kind of a slow beat.
Let's hear just a little bit more than that.
I'll start to play along and I want you to to count the number of bars,
number of measures in the pattern.
This is a pattern that repeats over and over in music.
When that pattern repeats,
we call it an Ostinato Austin Ra from the Italian word,
Austin,
Ra,
stubborn pigheaded.
So we have an Ostinato harmony here.
Um,
and how many bars is in this Ostinato are there in this Ostinato pattern?
[inaudible] and it's
going to continue again,
anybody able to count the number of bars in the pattern just on that one little
quick plane there?
Yeah.
Uh,
Betty 16.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
you're on the right track.
Roger Eight.
Yeah,
it was,
it was a 16 bar pattern.
It was a 60 week played 16 bars there,
but the harmony of the second eight bars was identical to the harmony of the
first eight bars.
It was just repeating same hormone.
What's the harmony?
MMM.
Is this piece by you to in major or minor?
How many think major raise your right here.
Sinister minor type Frazier.
Lefthand,
definitely in lighter.
So it's one of these unusual part pieces in minor.
Uh.
All right.
So that's cord one.
It's the titanic.
What about this?
Try it major.
Minor,
major about this one
major.
What about this one?
Okay,
then back to
minor.
Major
and mine at the end.
So that's our,
that's our eight bar pattern.
Now maybe even kind of sing along with this.
My question to you,
and this is the last room with this piece is,
is this a,
an example of a regular rate of harmonic change or an irregular rate of harmonic
change?
So here we go.
Maybe I'll just play it on the piano.
Just the simplest thing here.
Ready?
Go.
So what do you think?
Regular.
Irregular.
How many think regular?
How many think irregular?
It's actually you regular Sadie?
Yes.
Tell me why.
Anybody tell me why I start to put you on the spot here.
But you got it right
incident.
Well,
no,
they,
they were kind of falling.
Well they were falling on the meter.
Okay.
But there was one moment,
uh,
when something was a little bit different,
Elizabeth
lasted long.
Okay.
It lasted longer.
What's the it here?
No,
the core last long.
Okay.
At the end of the phrase
seven Oh six,
seven two.
So that one lasted two bars,
two,
three,
five,
two six,
two seven two eight two.
So one of those chords lasted actually called one of those cores toward the end
there lasted twice as long as all the others.
Roger a question
that last part,
um,
aid could conceivably be arrest,
but that would give us a kind of a seven bar phrase.
I don't like seven bar phrases.
Never met a seven bar phrase and it was really comfortable with,
and musicians generally don't like that,
so it's better to better to go with,
you know,
I,
I've used this for the first time in section the other day,
uh,
and I'll use it again here a second time.
OCKHAM's razor,
if there's a simple solution,
go for it.
Um,
so take the idea of symmetry and assume that it's an eight bar phrase and you've
got one court holding for extra cord.
But theoretically that's possible.
A question here.
Yeah.
Uh,
we would not get into that.
Um,
but it would still be considered regular.
All they're doing is filling between court.
Like Peter Salovey.
Okay.
All he's doing is,
and if he could
playing other things along the way,
that's still regular,
but that's far more sophisticated and we're,
we're ever going to get to,
we're just going to go plunk,
plunk,
plunk.
Okay.
So keep it very,
very much in the street in Nero.
All right,
we have one more idea to talk about and that is the concept of key and
modulation.
Now this piece by youtube
is written in a key.
It's got the home key.
Here's an odd kid,
B flat,
minor five flats B,
flat,
minor.
Uh,
but it nonetheless is a key and the pole piece,
at least the vast majority of it is in that one key.
Occasionally composers will change keys.
I was thinking I could play right for you here.
The Beethoven he started.
So here we are in this minor key.
So composers do Kate change keys and when they change keys,
they affect what's called a modulation.
Let's listen to an example of,
I think we have Copeland up next.
Okay.
Let's listen to an example of a pretty simple modulation affected by Aaron
Copeland,
American composer working in New York City.
Uh,
in the forties,
50s,
60s and 70s,
wrote a,
a ballet suite called Appalachian Spring.
And in it he has one section where he's working through a series of variations
on a folk tune called a gift to be simple.
And he,
he pulls off a modulation.
So let's listen to Copeland's Appalachian Spring as he proceeds and all kind of
try to duplicate and go crazy up here at the piano.
At the moment we get to the modulation.
Modulations are hard to hear.
The best you can do with it oftentimes and say,
this is unsettled.
Maybe it's modulating,
and we,
I don't,
I'm not even sure would ask you.
It has the piece modular.
They're really,
really kind of hard to hear,
but let's,
let's try it anyway.
So here's cope a Copeland modulation.
So here he is in this case.
Yeah,
I think this is where the modulation comes.
Then he's going to bring in the [inaudible]
sitting on this note.
He brings in the trombone
and then the trumpet will jump off from
yeah
to a much,
he was here.
Now he's modulated up to here.
So let's see if we can hear this modulation now.
Here we go.
So that's a modulation immune.
Conceptually it's pretty straight forward but it's hard to hear.
Uh,
I think I've got an e one that's easier to here.
It's a piece I like to use because it's just off the charts in terms of what
other popular music was doing at that time.
It's piece by the Beach Boys Beach Boys Music is extremely interesting.
Whether the California airheads,
no,
no.
This is really musically,
it's just light years ahead of what everybody else was doing,
I guess late fifties,
early,
early sixties.
So what I've got here on the board is a harmonic scheme and we're going to for
once again for copyright reasons,
just take little chunks of this.
Um,
but you can see that it's a,
it's a piece that changes,
uses a lot of triad.
So every time you see a g up here,
that means we have a cord build on g and the try it on e try it on a tryout on
f,
d e And just looking at this,
this isn't shaping out to be one,
four,
five one.
So it's moving around a lot.
Then it gets to a section where it does get very boring.
It's very static at that particular point,
and then something of interest will happen.
So let's listen to a little bit of this.
And there are,
it's a piece in which they are contrast between sections of movement with a lot
of wild modulations and then,
uh,
sections of Stacy's Brown,
Brown
kid around.
I get around
here,
it gets very boring and we're not going to even listen to it.
Just going to sit there.
I'm really hip and I'm having a great time,
but then the text comes back to,
um,
I get around.
So let's,
I think that's what I've had to parse this thing out and do a Frankenstein.
But let's,
let's listen to the next thing.
I think we go back to the idea of,
I get around
[inaudible]
duff,
more boring stuff at this point,
but let's pick it up as we come to the end of what I think is this boring stuff
and we'll listen to what they do there.
[inaudible]
go ahead.
so they're sitting here in which,
yeah,
so what kind of cadence is they've given us their deceptive cadence,
deceptive cadence and that
a half step and then it,
no,
it doesn't jump to the Aaron Copeland Appalachian Spring,
but it does the same thing.
It does exactly the same thing.
It uses that inner beyond them.
It's going to jump up from the dominant to the tonic and then slide up one more
thing.
So that we have now a whole section in a flat and the original was in GE,
so he's modulated to a flat.
It's extremely sophisticated involving half-step modulations and things like
that.
Who would have thunk that from the B from the beach boys?
Uh,
all right,
we're going to stop here.
Uh,
we've got sections this week.
We have a test that week from today.
If you look at your emails later in the day,
you will see a,
an email from me saying that we are posting a prep sheet for the tests and it
will tell you all you need to know and how to study over the weekend for the
test next Thursday.
So let's listen to a little bit of the Erin Copeland as you go out.